J'avais l'air d'un randonneur perdu qui était trop près du bord.
(Rires)
J'étais entouré de gens au téléphone ou en train de pique-niquer.
On aurait dit un centre commercial.
(Rires)
J'ai retiré mes chaussures d'escalade et commencé la descente,
et là, les gens m'ont arrêté :
« Tu randonnes pieds nus ? C'est du lourd ! »
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Je n'ai pas cherché à expliquer.
(Rires)
Ce soir-là, dans mon journal d'escalade, j'ai consigné mon solo du Half Dome,
mais j'ai ajouté un smiley triste et un commentaire : « Faire mieux ? »
J'avais réussi le solo,
reconnu comme une première dans le monde de l'escalade.
Des amis en ont fait un film.
Mais je n'étais pas satisfait.
J'étais déçu de ma performance
car je savais que j'avais eu du bol.
Je ne voulais pas être juste chanceux, mais être un grand grimpeur.
En fait, j'ai arrêté le solo intégral pendant un an,
pour ne pas m'habituer à compter sur la chance.
Mais même sans faire beaucoup de solos,
j'avais déjà commencé à penser à El Cap.
Ça restait, dans mon esprit, le plus prestigieux des solos.
C'est le mur le plus impressionnant au monde.
Chaque année, pendant les sept années suivantes,
je pensais : « C'est cette année que je vais grimper El Cap. »
Et je roulais jusqu'à Yosemite, je regardais le mur, en pensant :
« Aucune chance. »
(Rires)
C'est trop grand et trop effrayant.
Mais j'en suis finalement venu à intégrer que je voulais me tester sur El Cap.
C'était le symbole de l'excellence.
Mais je voulais l'appréhender autrement.
Je ne voulais pas avoir du bol ou m'en sortir de justesse.
Cette fois, je voulais faire ça bien.
Ce qui rend El Cap si intimidant,
c'est la pente abrupte de la paroi.
La plupart des grimpeurs mettent 3 à 5 jours
pour grimper les 900 mètres de granite vertical.
L'idée de me lancer sur un mur de cette taille
avec seulement des chaussures et un sac de craie semblait impossible.
900 mètres de montée représentent
des milliers de mouvements distincts,
c'est beaucoup à retenir.
J'en connaissais beaucoup en les ayant juste répétés.
J'avais monté El Cap environ 50 fois en 10 ans, avec une corde.
Mais cette photo montre ma méthode préférée pour répéter les mouvements.
Je suis au sommet,
sur le point de descendre avec une corde de 300 mètres
et passer la journée à m'entraîner.
Si je trouvais des séquences sûres et reproductibles,
je devais les mémoriser.
Je devais m'assurer qu'elles étaient ancrées en moi pour éviter toute erreur.
Je ne voulais pas me retrouver sur le mur à douter du tracé ou de mes prises.
Je voulais que tout vienne naturellement.
Grimper avec une corde est un effort surtout physique.
Il faut juste être assez fort pour s'accrocher et monter.
Mais le solo intégral sollicite plus le mental.
L'effort physique est en gros le même :
votre corps grimpe le même mur.
Mais rester calme et être au top de vous-même
quand la moindre erreur peut entraîner la mort,
ça demande un certain état d'esprit.
(Rires)
Ce n'est pas censé faire rire, mais soit.
J'ai cultivé cet état d'esprit, à travers la visualisation,
ce qui revient à imaginer l'expérience du solo intégral sur la paroi.
C'était pour m'aider à me rappeler les prises,
mais surtout pour sentir la texture de chaque prise dans ma main
et imaginer la sensation d'étendre le pied et le placer de telle ou telle façon.
J'imaginais tout ça comme une chorégraphie à des centaines de mètres de haut.
La partie la plus difficile du tracé était le Boulder Problem.
C'était à environ 600 mètres du sol
et nécessitait les mouvements les plus durs du parcours :
longues tractions entre faibles prises, très petites et glissantes.
Voilà ce que j'entends par faible prise :
un bord plus petit que la largeur d'un crayon, et tourné vers le bas,
sur lequel je devais m'appuyer avec mon pouce.
Mais ce n'était même pas ça le plus dur.
Le passage-clef était délicat,
avec mon pied gauche dirigé vers l'intérieur d'un coin proche,
une manœuvre qui demandait un haut degré de précision et souplesse,
à tel point que j'avais fait des étirements chaque soir
pendant toute une année avant ça
pour pouvoir m'assurer d'atteindre aisément cet endroit avec mon pied.
En répétant ces mouvements,
ma visualisation s'est focalisée sur l'aspect émotionnel d'un solo potentiel.
Et si je montais là-haut et que c'était trop effrayant ?
Et si j'étais trop fatigué ?
Et si je n'étais pas assez souple ?
Je devais tout évaluer pendant que j'étais encore au sol, en sécurité,
pour que, quand je ferai les mouvements sans corde,
je ne sois pas assailli par le doute.
Le doute précède la peur,
et je savais que je ne pouvais pas savourer ce moment en ayant peur.
Je devais visualiser et répéter suffisamment pour éliminer tout doute.
Mais en plus, je devais visualiser comment ce serait
si ça ne paraissait jamais faisable.
Et si, après tout ce boulot, j'avais peur de me lancer ?
Et si je perdais mon temps,
et que je n'étais jamais à l'aise dans une position aussi exposée ?
Difficile à dire,
mais El Cap valait bien tous ces efforts.
Certains préparatifs étaient plus terre-à-terre.
Voici une photo de mon ami Conrad Anker
en train de grimper El Cap avec un sac à dos vide.
On a passé la journée à grimper vers une fissure bien précise,
qui était remplie de pierres.
Ça rendait cette partie difficile et potentiellement dangereuse,
car un faux pas pouvait en faire tomber une
et tuer un autre grimpeur ou un randonneur.
Donc nous les avons délicatement enlevées, mises dans le sac,
et sommes descendus avec.
Imaginez une seconde à quel point ça semble ridicule
de grimper un mur de 600 mètres juste pour remplir un sac de pierres.
(Rires)
Ce n'est jamais facile de porter un sac de pierres.
C'est encore plus dur le long d'une falaise.
Ça avait l'air bête, mais ça devait être fait.
Je voulais que tout soit parfait avant de grimper sur ce tracé sans corde.
Après deux saisons d'entraînement focalisé sur un solo intégral sur El Cap,
j'avais enfin bouclé mes préparatifs.
Je connaissais chaque prise du tracé,
et je savais exactement quoi faire.
En somme, j'étais prêt.
Il était temps d'affronter El Cap en solo.
Le 3 juin 2017,
je me suis levé tôt, j'ai pris mon petit-déj habituel, de muesli et fruits,
et suis allé au pied avant le lever du soleil.
Je me sentais confiant en regardant en haut.
Je me sentais encore mieux en commençant l'ascension.
Après environ 200 mètres, j'ai atteint une dalle,
très similaire à celle qui m'avait posé problème au Half Dome.
Mais, ici, c'était différent.
J'avais évalué chaque option, sur des dizaines de mètres de chaque côté.
Je savais exactement quoi faire, et comment le faire.
Je ne doutais pas, j'ai simplement continué mon ascension.
Même les portions les plus ardues, je les ai franchies aisément.
J'exécutais mon programme à la perfection.
Je me suis un peu reposé en dessous du Boulder Problem,
et ensuite, je l'ai grimpé comme je l'avais fait avant avec la corde.
Mon pied s'est planté dans le mur vers la gauche sans hésiter,
et j'ai su que c'était bon.
Grimper le Half Dome avait été un gros objectif, qui était atteint,
mais je n'avais pas obtenu ce que je voulais.
Je n'avais pas excellé.
J'étais hésitant et effrayé, et ce n'était pas comme ça que je l'avais voulu.
Mais El Cap a été différent.
A 240 mètres du sommet, c'est comme si la montagne m'offrait un tour d'honneur.
Mon ascension était fluide et précise
et j'appréciais le bruit des oiseaux volant autour de moi.
C'était comme une cérémonie.
Et puis, j'ai atteint le sommet,
après 3 heures et 56 minutes de glorieuse ascension.
C'était comme je le voulais, un sentiment d'excellence.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)